to talk about the industry participation
and how industry is involved in this
program and what are the additional
benefits that one could get from such an
industry academic partnership for this
Innovative PG diploma and certification
program
so today we are learning we have learned
and discussed and heard from different
speakers about the importance of big
data and how it is playing a critical
role in Next Generation sequencing and
data applications of data science and
other Technologies so I think combining
all of this what we are looking at is
uh is three different aspects biology
data science and uh informatics so in
this training program we have been
discussing and designing those
curriculums that covers all those
aspects so that a person who is coming
from a beginner level can easily learn
through the basics of biology basics of
computational Sciences as well as
and the different types of algorithms
and Technologies and advanced statistics
that we will be covering in these uh in
this training program so
um in in such a way that in today's
world um there is a lot of impact for
anything you do so we just have to
realize that impact and every line of
code that you write every line of uh
program and every compiled program that
you do could play a very important role
for healthcare data analysis that would
impact the real world
directly so uh in that context we are
trying to understand that what are the
important things that are the industry
is looking at so we look at all the job
opportunities that are there in this
specific fields and then we try to
identify that what are the areas then
pharmaceutical companies as well as
biotech biotechnology companies and
different other uh areas that you just
saw in the mind mind map that Professor
mukherji showed you uh is like a
combination of you know all of those
things that you need to learn and how to
make it in a way that you learn it with
ease and also try to implement it so we
have compiled all of this put together
lines of you know data sets and coding
lessons and uh different ways you can
analyze data using platform-based
Technologies and also code-based
Technologies
so in that you get to learn from an
interface where you kind of understand
each of these steps that we are kind of
taking in having an understanding of how
the data is looking what the different
types of you know commands are doing so
not just a black box but a very detailed
understanding of all of this how this
could be uh useful for different types
of research areas and uh aspects of uh
training that we will be covering so
another important aspects aspect of this
type of training is to be able to
Foster collaboration in research areas
and topics many of you might be
interested in doing a uh you know
postdoctoral fellowship or a PhD or a
master's program where you have maybe
aspiration to go abroad and gain some
other type of experience working with
some of the Cutting Edge Laboratories so
thus this type of training and this type
of research which is like research-based
training is absolutely mandatory and it
kind of helps you a lot to get to those
opportunities may that be a master's
opportunity may that be a postdoctoral
opportunity or may that be a job
opportunity so integration of these type
of data uh in today's world especially
in U.S and other high income countries
are rapidly used and as ma'am was
telling you that in India this has been
an honor rise and uh that leads to
different types of job opportunities
internship opportunities and experience
building opportunities so we all are
participating in that and there is a lot
of uh demand
where there are every day we are posting
job opportunities and in this experience
once you have the training once you have
the skill sets and then you uh have the
experience to work on different types of
data sets you would understand that what
these type of you know organizations are
seeking and that would be a great
opportunity for anyone to go and you
know experience this so in combining all
of this uh is what we have been doing so
Pine biotech and omics logic is a
us-based company and we have our Academy
collaborations around the globe uh this
entire omics Logic Technology has been
developed by Dr
Alfred Tauber Dr Leonard Brodsky who is
a mathematician and also has great
expertise in one of the key skill sets
which is like mathematical modeling
developing new algorithms finding
solutions to different types of
biological problems and really those
problems that we have not even seen
these team members are working on uh
like ahead of us and they are developing
these technologies that we are kind of
using and are being used uh in in some
time because some of the Technologies
such as spatial spatial transcriptomics
and then you are looking at the
application on aging and different types
of things and then you're looking at how
it is uh kind of helping in vaccine
development so these are the
technologies that are the forefronts of
Dober bioinformatics Research Center
which is headed by Dr Julia penov who is
the assistant director associate
director of the top of mindful exercise
Center and during this program also uh
when we reached to a level where you are
kind of working on projects uh the
entire team will be uh will be glad to
help you and provide you with expertise
that are required for you to gain uh
similarly we have an amazing team in
India who will be supporting this
program throughout your journey so uh
giving you opportunities uh that are
available on through different companies
uh through different research and
academic institutions as well as helping
you through the program by introducing
to this different types of data sets
different types of algorithmic
approaches and also helping you with
that sort of project where you are kind
of implementing maybe generating data or
utilizing some data from public
repositories and then using it for your
own research so we have an excellent
team who will be able to guide you
through this entire uh process so as uh
as pankaj said that we have been doing
this for a while and we have several we
have trained severals and thousands of
students and collaborated with top
research and academic institutions
around the globe and uh we kind of
specialized in omics technology and
multiomic integration and multinomics
Technologies as well as data science
machine learning and uh using artificial
intelligence for a better you know
understanding even for education so you
will get glimpses of that you will get
experience of that and you will also
learn that how generative AI for example
is is making things much more you know
faster easier and you're kind of
covering a lot so those type of
applications which are just like you
know are coming up we kind of integrate
into the curriculum so that you are more
relevant for the industry to get hired
so in this training program I would say
this is a very unique training program
as said by Dr Professor Mukherjee
because this is one of a kind and uh
there the curriculum that we have
prepared is very uh neat and really
relates to what is happening around the
world but at the same time this is also
a great opportunity for those who are
working professionals so this training
program actually helps those people who
are doing like jobs on Monday to Friday
and then they can completely you know
learn and do everything over the
weekends as most of the sessions are
going to be scheduled over the weekends
so that you if you're doing some other
higher degrees and if you are like
working in a company you can participate
and upskill yourself and kind of get uh
different types of opportunity that can
change your you know profile to your
salary structure to 2X or 4X so that's
uh our motivation as well to help you
learn on this technology but also not
only for you know getting good salaries
but also for solving Global challenges
so right now you saw the impact of covet
you saw the impact of different types of
situations we are facing from climate
change to global warming bioinformatics
the Next Generation data and oming's
data and bio data science is kind of
been applied at all of these problems so
there's a huge opportunity
for you to not only earn well but also
contribute to the world for good
so uh um in the context of you know not
just you know improving all of this but
also saving a lot of uh maybe money
saving a lot of time is also why this
program is such an important program for
those who are kind of you know
experienced want to experience from data
generation to data analysis to you know
writing a paper and completing a paper
to you know later finding uh key ways to
apply for Grants so all of those things
are like uh in a in a pipeline you can
understand that one can be achieved just
after completing another so in that
context uh when we learn about these
Technologies from the experts uh we get
to know that what we not what we do what
we have to you know avoid what are the
common mistakes and in that sense you
kind of end up saving a lot of your time
and lot of your money uh with the failed
experiments which you will be more
efficient towards and understand with a
deeper understanding of what is
happening with the instrument and the
data that you have gotten if that data
is making sense at all for your research
questions so what happens is that as you
learned about there are so many
opportunities there are so many good
things and all of that but when you when
you're going to do this there is also a
lot of expectation so there would be
expectations from the pi there would be
expectations from the company so doing
it right is kind of uh very important
for the industry and that's why these
type of paths that we have curated for
you is very important for you to go
through because these are these kind of
addresses all those challenges so uh we
will start with uh as I said the deeper
understanding and all of that is
important for you to also develop a
logic so we will use different types of
Technologies for you to help with that
help you understand that logic and
practice that and also gain an uh
hands-on experience of on all of this so
from learning about different types of
algorithms how they work in in in in a
sync and what kind of results we can
expect from such experiments and what
are the challenges really like there is
is a lot of challenge with big data
analysis and you can absolutely get lost
in it because there is so much
information that it sometimes does not
make sense to make sense so to do that
you need uh experience working with data
you need to know the patterns uh and
like what kind of patterns you can
expect and even if you don't get
patterns what are the ways to you know
improve your results uh so those are the
things that you would learn from a
person who has experienced and have been
doing this for all the time so we as a
company have been working on this all
the time and have curated all of this
experience so that one can learn about
this Technologies end to end from very
beginner perspective to an end
result which would be you know different
types of outcomes that I was telling you
so all of this is going to be available
for you in this one year training
program and with Within These different
type of certification programs and you
will be able to learn not only
propriety softwares but open source
Technologies Cloud servers biological
data sets machine learning AI
application of application of AI and
then again all of this would make sense
if you are able to collaborate and
forced Foster this and provide such
opportunities for others we have a group
of academic Partners whom we are working
with regularly and we kind of work on
different types of things like for
Education there is a there is
opportunities for uh for research
there's a lot of opportunities so we're
working with uh you know naguchi
Memorial Institute of medical research
on malaria we are working with all India
Institute of Medical Sciences in the
department of pathology so these are
different collaborations for different
types of you know research areas
research problems and that's where you
get like get opportunity to work on
different types of projects in
collaboration and maybe Envision
different types of out such as
Publications or
or learning uh how to do go about it
similarly we have different types
different industry partners and we are
very closely working closely working
with these industry Partners whom we are
like either collaborating for by
informatics products or they are
providing mentorships for students and
collaborations for data driven
translational research and then we reach
out to them for internships and job
opportunities career guidance and
placements and we conduct Symposium and
startups and hackathons our account mix
that kind of gives the student platform
to generate uh work on their idea and
work on uh and go for a startup so all
of those opportunities are there uh I'm
really happy and really glad to meet uh
meet all of you today and we'll be
looking forward for your participation
and this entire Journey which is really
really exciting because there are so
many things that one could achieve so
that will be all from my present
thank you